who was um with all the people you've
worked with you've worked with everyone
drake travis we can go on nikki et
cetera
um as far as like in studio experience
whose creative process is like the most
meticulous
where you're just like yo this this is
like different because i always hear
like guys like dr dre's creative process
is insane like he's so particular about
like the smallest [ __ ] and i've been in
sessions with artists that like care
about
[ __ ] that you wouldn't even like think
of like who's that artist that you've
been in with that just very over the top
with just caring about the small details
them
um
probably just like i don't know i feel
like a lot of artists do but um
definitely like the atlanta artists like
quavo the migos
um thug future i feel like guys that
just freestyle everything they do but
then like they're also like so like
aware of like how they're saying it like
their tone and like their vocals and
[ __ ] like that's pretty crazy you know
what i'm saying i have this thing that i
always say about producers like i mean
uh artists and [ __ ] like it's like if
they get it or they don't get it and
like it's like
i feel like
how like party could like go and just
freestyle whole song and it's like
incredible or like juice world could
like freestyle whole beating it would be
like an incredible song y w melee the
same it's like certain artists just got
it like you know what i'm saying like
like you could just pull up a beat for
juice rp or like melee parties and they
were just going just they could
literally freestyle the whole beat and
it's like a finished song that shit's
crazy that's incredible is it a
different like uh when you're in with a
producer that does that that does the
punch-in thing or does the off-the-top
thing as opposed to somebody who writes
[ __ ] i don't even know who writes it
down anymore because it feels like most
people just go in and they do they they
do the melody or they they do the
punching thing where they punch in line
by line like is there like a big
difference for you like being in the
studio who actually writes 100 so like
it was like a gift and a curse with
amigos because i was like so young i was
like 19 20 years old working with these
guys they're freestyling everything
punching in and stuff and then when i
started working with other people and
people were writing i like didn't have
patience in the studio for it because
it's like it's a much more patience like
driven process yeah like i could go i
could go in with amigos they could pull
up a beat half of the song done in 20
minutes i was cooking up beats in like
30 minutes 20 minutes so i was like our
workflow was so quick but our chemistry
was crazy you know what i'm saying so
it's like then going in with someone who
has to sit there and write some people
write for an hour some people aren't as
quick with it you know i'm saying it's
not a bad thing everyone's creative it's
just a different process
i'll just be like man what the [ __ ] are
we doing let's move on to the next
record yeah you know he's like i'm gonna
go to dave's hot chicken and come back
let me know when you're ready shout out
daison chicken